a few weeks ago
I posted a video
talking about how I was so thankful
that I don't have to wear a Jean skirt when I play sports anymore
and the comments were absolutely bizarre
so many people related to what I had to say and then others were very offended
something that I talk about a lot on my page
is how much my life has drastically changed since I left legalism
and have built a real relationship with Jesus
if you were up in legalism
a high control group or maybe even a cult
I'm sure you can relate
your perspective on life when you're in something like that is just so small
your world is so small
you've been taught to believe a certain set of beliefs and that's it
and you're expected to follow those beliefs or standards without question
for me it's been a lot of asking myself okay
is this what scripture teaches
or is this what I was taught to believe by man
I want to honour and please the Lord in everything that I do
not because a man told me to
but because that's what actually glorifies the Lord
this affects every area of my life
including my job
my marriage my friendships
all of my relationship
and yes even the clothes that I wear
if you're working through something similar or you can relate to this at all
I just want to encourage you that you're not alone
you're not crazy
give yourself time
give yourself Grace
god is good
you can walk out of this and still have a great relationship with Jesus